my name is Melanie Fox I create the AP
macroeconomics and ap microeconomics
content for Khan Academy well if you if
you don't develop that mindset and you
say I can't overcome this this barrier
you've just made that barrier permanent
for yourself so for me I because I loved
economics so much it was just a way of
finding away around those barriers
whether that was taking fewer classes to
give myself more time to concentrate in
the areas that I struggled with taking
classes in the summer where I could
focus on just one class at a time that
helped me a lot to get get past those
barriers the day I walked out of my
calculus one final exam and I knew that
I had aced it and I don't think I had
aced a math class since fifth grade and
that was just you for it I remember I
can even remember the price of gasoline
when I walked out of the building after
that exam because it was just such a
vivid memory of I did it I I was finally
able to overcome this it's okay to
struggle it's it's probably better to
struggle than to not struggle because if
you if you can get through things very
very easily when you hit that first
barrier you don't know what to do and it
it it's good to have the experience to
hit a barrier and find a way to push
back that